so we have a system of two linear
equations here this first equation x
minus 4y is equal to negative 18. and
the second equation negative x plus 3y
is equal to 11.
now what we're going to do is find an x
and y pair that satisfies both of these
equations that's what solving the system
actually means as you might already have
seen there's a bunch of x and y pairs
that satisfy this first equation in fact
if you were to graph them they would
form a line and there's a bunch of other
x and y pairs that satisfy this other
equation the second equation and if you
were to graph them it would form a line
and so if you find the x and y pair that
satisfy both that would be the
intersection of the lines so let's do
that
so actually i'm just going to rewrite
the first equation over here so i'm
going to write x minus 4y is equal to
negative 18.
so we've already seen in algebra that as
long as we do the same thing to both
sides of the equation we can maintain
our equality so what if we were to add
and our goal here is to eliminate one of
the variables so we have one equation
with one unknown so what if we were to
add
this negative x plus 3y to the left-hand
side here so negative x plus 3y well
that looks pretty good because an x and
a negative x are going to cancel out
and we are going to be left with
negative 4y plus 3y well that's just
going to be negative y
so by adding the left-hand side of this
bottom equation to the left-hand side of
the top equation we were able to cancel
out the x's we had x and we had a
negative x that was very nice for us so
what do we do on the right hand side
we've already said that we have to add
the same thing to both sides of an
equation
we might be tempted
we might be tempted to
just say well if i have to add the same
thing to both sides well maybe i have to
maybe have to add a negative x plus 3y
to that side but that's not going to
help us much we're going to have
negative 18 minus x plus 3y we won't we
would have introduced an x on the right
hand side of the equation but what if we
could add something that's equivalent to
negative x plus 3y that
does not introduce the x variable
well we know that the number 11 is
equivalent to negative x plus 3y why do
how do we know that well that second
equation tells us that so once again all
i'm doing is i'm adding the same thing
to both sides of that top equation on
the left i'm expressing it as negative x
plus 3y but the second equation tells us
that
that negative x plus 3y is going to be
equal to 11. it's introducing that
second that second constraint
and so let's add 11 to the right hand
side which is once again i know i keep
repeating it's the same thing as
negative x plus 3y so negative 18 plus
11 is negative 7. and since we added the
same thing to both sides the equi
quality still holds and we get negative
y is equal to negative seven
or divide both sides by negative one or
multiply both sides by negative one
so multiply both sides by negative one
we get y
is equal to 7. so we have the y
coordinate of the xy pair that satisfies
the both of these now how do we find the
x
well we can just substitute this y
equals 7 to either one of these when y
equals 7 we should get the same x
regardless of which equation we use so
let's use the top equation so we know
that x
minus 4 times instead of writing y i'm
going to write 4 times 7 because we're
going to figure out what is x when y is
7
that is going to be equal to negative 18
and so see negative 4 or 4 times 7 that
is 28
so let's see i could to solve for x i
can add 28 to both sides so add
28
to both sides
on the left hand side negative 28
positive 28 those cancel out i'm just
left with an x and on the right hand
side i get negative 8 negative 18 plus
28 is 10. so there you have it i have
the xy pairs that status or the xy pair
that satisfies both
x equals 10 y equals 7. i could write it
here
so i could write it as coordinates i
could write it as 10
comma 7. and notice what i just did here
i encourage you substitute y equals 7
here and you will also get x equals 10.
either way you would have you would have
come to x equals 10. and to visualize
what is going on here
let's visualize it really fast let me
draw some coordinate axes whoops
i meant to draw a straighter line than
that all right there you go so let's say
that is our y-axis
and
that is
that is
whoops
that is our x-axis
and then
let's see this the top lot the top
equation is going to look something
like this
it's going to look something like this
and then that bottom equation is going
to look something
something
like
let me draw a little bit nicer than that
it's going to look something like this
something like that let me draw that
bottom one here so you see the point
of intersection
and so the point of intersection right
over here
that is an xy pair that satisfies both
of these equations and that we just saw
it happens when x is equal to
10
and y
is equal to
7. once again this white line that's all
the x and y pairs that satisfy the top
equation this orange line that's all the
x and y pairs that satisfy the orange
equation and where they intersect that
point is on both lines it satisfies both
equations and once again take x equals
10 y equals 7 substitute it back into
either one of these and you will see
that it holds